morning everyone it's at seven o'clock
almost a year since Russia invaded
Ukraine this morning Vladimir Putin will
set out his take on the war in the state
of the nation address back home pressure
on the government to send fighter jets
to Ukraine with two former Prime
Ministers weighing in last night we'll
have the latest through the morning live
from Moscow Kiev and Warsaw where
President Biden will also be speaking
later on plus as Junior doctors vote to
strike we'll be joined by the health
Minister Maria Caufield shortly it's
Tuesday the 21st of February
the Russian President Vladimir Putin
will give his assessment of the war in
Ukraine almost a year since he sent in
his troops
the key of ukrainians wait to hear
details about the big new support
package from President Biden as
Britain's prime minister is yet again
urged to send fast Jets
which is the next cabinet meets this
morning behind the scenes negotiations
continue as he inches closer to a new
post-brexit trade deal for Northern
Ireland
UK supermarkets facing a tomato shortage
poor weather in Europe and Africa means
shops are short of some fruit and veg
the rescue mission underway again in
Turkey after it's struck by another
earthquake just weeks after the disaster
which killed tens of thousands of people
[Music]
and the baby girl born beneath the
rubble in Syria finds a new home after
her miraculous rescue
[Music]
morning everyone very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
the Russian President Vladimir Putin
will make an address to the nation later
this morning or is expected to lay out
his aims for the second year of his
invasion of Ukraine he'll speak a day
after the U.S president's symbolic visit
to Kiev where he promised to stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes Joe
Biden is now in Warsaw where he'll meet
the Polish president later on today and
reiterate America's support for Ukraine
and NATO's Eastern flank our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wyckord is in Warsaw for us this morning
Dominic updators
okay in a couple of hours we're going to
hear from Vladimir Putin he will give a
key speech ahead of the anniversary of
his invasion of Ukraine we'll hear his
plans we hope to hear some of his plans
at least for the year ahead is he going
to up the ante will he declare war now
on Ukraine will he mobilize hundreds of
thousands more troops is he going to
step up uh this war he's waging he's
been waging against Ukraine for more
than well almost a year now or is he
going to back off at all and then this
afternoon we're going to hear from
President Biden in The Gardens of the
royal castle here in Warsaw behind me
he'll be giving remarks so not being
staged as a speech as such but remarks
but we'll be watching very closely his
his visit to Kiev yesterday was compared
to some of the memorable moments of the
Cold War JFK's speech in 1963 in West
Berlin when he used those Immortal words
igbin ein Berliner I am a Berliner or
the speech that Ronald Reagan gave in
the same city in 1987 where he said to
Mr Gorbachev tear down this wall all the
visit itself has been compared to those
moments but we didn't really hear the
words to match the moment from President
Biden is he going to find the kind of
oratory to suit the moment this
afternoon and how is he going to
announce the coming year in terms of the
West's response to this war he'll be a
meeting with a Polish president Angie do
that this morning and then with other
allies tomorrow as they trying to
Grapple with their response to what
Vladimir Putin says this morning
now Dominic thank you here at home uh
two of the prime minister's predecessors
have piled pressure on him to send
fighter jets to Ukraine Boris Johnson
and Liz trust spoke in the Commons
during a debate on Ukraine Rishi sunat
hasn't directly committed to a such move
but has said nothing is off the table
it's admirable that we're proposing to
train Ukrainian fighters to fly NATO
fast Jets I hear the uh the caution of
my honorable friend but it's curious
that we're doing this before we even
taken the decision in principle to give
them the planes let's cut to the Chase
and give them the planes we need to do
all we can as fast as we can my view is
that does include fighter jets so let's
work with our allies to get them an
option uh to be able to use because
otherwise they won't be able to prevail
Debra's in care for us this morning
um so the talk continues about fighter
jets are way off yet though I think
yes and it's a bit Rich for those two
former Prime Ministers to start talking
so strongly and passionately about
sending fast Jets given that when they
were in office they didn't sanction that
either and the ukrainians have been
asking for this kind of equipment since
the very beginning of this full-scale
war the other factor that they glossed
over is that we just don't have fast
debts in enough numbers with enough
support packages to be able to sustain
them to be able to give to the
ukrainians anytime soon everybody that I
have spoken to says it's it's farcical
to think that the UK can in any
meaningful way in the time that Ukraine
needs them I.E right now send fast debts
it's much more of a decision for other
European allies and the United States
those that are flying the F-16 for
example which are in much greater number
therefore have much more support
packages behind them and those are the
depths really that people to be thinking
about when it comes to that big decision
whether or not to send for our steps but
what is true is the UK has over the past
year really LED in terms of urging
others to take these new Bolder steps
for example with tanks which Rishi sunak
did lead the way on so maybe it is true
that the UK could perhaps be a bit more
forward-leaning when it comes to
encouraging other countries to give
these Jets while maybe acknowledging
more frankly that right now it doesn't
have the kit to be able to do the same I
just um I know you were there yesterday
morning when President Biden came to
town I heard you talking about it
yesterday when you were on the balcony
I'm sure your experience with our
breakfast viewers this morning
but it was incredible there was so much
speculation mounting about who might be
coming to town we're staying at a hotel
right by the square well you know it
well you stayed there too
um where the the president and his
Ukrainian host did a tour and the day
before we'd all receive kind of letters
to our doors telling us that there was
going to be a big security procedure
happening the next morning that we
wouldn't be allowed even on the
balconies there was going to be no
filming from the balconies and then in
the morning there were suddenly soldiers
appearing inside sort of telling us not
to um to stand on these balconies to be
able to look out and and film what was
going on and the road outside too was
completely locked down and then suddenly
there he was the press the U.S president
walking in the Square where those tanks
those those um destroyed Russian tanks
which mark this this sort of display of
defiance by the ukrainians are standing
and then very poignantly going to the
memorial wall that runs along the side
of the monastery exterior which pays
tribute to Ukraine's war dead not just
from over the past 12 months but of
course since 2014 which is when Russia
really began this war with its
annexation of Crimea
okay for now Deborah thank you
and we will hear from President Biden
later on today he is in uh where is he
is and also later on this morning we'll
be hearing from President Putin who is
in Moscow and he will be speaking from 9
00 am
foreign
three people have been killed and more
than 600 injured after another
earthquake struck the Border region
between turkey and Syria that's the area
devastated by Massive earthquakes two
weeks ago 47 000 people are confirmed to
have died during those first two
earthquakes and Alistair standing by for
us this morning hello to you Alistair
um another earthquake
yeah two in fact last night uh one
measuring 6.4 on scale another 5.8 very
shallow depth two kilometers that's
about 1.2 miles beneath the surface
slightly further south than the major
earthquake that hit a couple of weeks
ago right on the turkey Syria border
Turkey as you just saying have reported
three people were killed last night more
than 200 injured over in Syria no
reports of fatalities yet from last
night's shaking but 500 people injured
some of them as they jumped out of
buildings trying to find safety I mean
the nerves will be incredibly frayed
given what they've been going through
over the last couple of weeks and people
are very much on edge very frightened
about what might happen other reports as
well the buildings collapsed as a result
of those two earthquakes last night that
were fought across the region including
down here in Israel 47 000 uh people are
estimated to have been killed in the
major earthquake a couple of weeks ago
many many are still missing Anthony
blink and the U.S Secretary of State was
in Ankara to meet the Turkish president
type Richard erdogan yesterday he said
that the U.S will continue to provide
turkey with whatever help it needs for
as long as it needs it but really the
recovery operation is starting to wind
down now and the focus is on the
humanitarian aspect to it to providing
shelter food water Etc but also starting
to reconstruct many of those buildings
that are so badly damaged okay for now
thank you
police have launched a murder
investigation following the death of a
17 year old boy in Huddersfield officers
were called to Kingsmill Lane in
Huddersfield just before 4 a.m on Monday
to find a teenage boy suffering from
serious stab wounds he died later in
hospital two males aged 37 and 14 have
been arrested on suspicion of attempted
murder a 19 year old woman has also been
arrested
DCI Alan weeks from West Yorkshire
police force who's leading the
investigation said we believe the attack
was targeted and are continuing to hold
two males in custody for what has now
become a murder inquiry he added I am
appealing for Witnesses and information
from the public and would like to speak
with anyone who saw the attack on the
victim or suspicious activity in the
Kings Mill Lane area
women in England will soon be able to
get a Year's worth of menopause HRT
treatment for less than 20 pounds a
scheme to cut prescription costs kicks
in on the 1st of April let's get more
should we with Ashna um hi Ashner tell
us more about this and also what about
women who came can't take HRT the
government catering for them as well
good morning Kay this is specifically
targeting women who are able to take HRT
it does benefit some 15 of women that
already use it in England aged 45 to 64.
and for many women it can be so
beneficial when relieving many symptoms
when it comes to the perimenopause or
the menopause itself and this is the
drugs that would be covered under this
scheme whether it's patches or gels or
tablets to tell us a little bit more how
this would work is Michael who owns this
pharmacist Pharmacy Michael talk to us
about this scheme then what difference
is it going to make to women and how
does it work first of all first of all I
mean the scheme is similar to the
current scheme that it operates whereby
patients pay either quarterly or yearly
for it also get more than four items of
um three months so the Skin's already
there so this is going to be similar to
that so the women are going to pay
around 18 pounds and it will be Exempted
for the whole year whatever they get or
I mean for the HRT operations instead of
paying 9.35 for each prescription they
get so it's going to be really really
beneficial to women in England every
woman in England who is going to be I
mean who's going to be who's going
through the prayer I mean menopausal
symptoms so in effect
um it's a win-win for women and I think
I'm I think it's gonna be so good and
it's also relief uh most women of the
burden of paying for prescription all
the time that they come in but they are
sometimes distressing scenes that we
tend to experience when women are going
through tough time but unfortunately
they're having difficulty paying for
their prescription so now see HRT is
really helpful for many women we know it
can really help with their symptoms what
about for women who aren't able to take
it because it can have a very different
impact for lots of different people
can't it how will this scheme help that
okay will this scheme help those who
can't take HRT oh definitely it's worth
it I mean you mean the country I mean
they can't Decay Charles obviously they
see their GP and their other
Alternatives that can be provided for
them there are so many kinds of fatality
depends upon depending upon the content
in the estrogen or the historical
content therefore it is targeted based
on the clinical history of the of the
woman so in in effect even if they they
are not taking the HRT as if they will
benefit from other sources but I believe
that generally there are so many women I
mean obviously but almost everybody is
using it and therefore it's going to be
of so much benefit to them
saving them some money giving relieving
them of the the stress and making it
easy for them to assess you know
prescriptions as well they need you know
instead of going through all their
hardships thank you very very much what
Michael was saying earlier is that
sometimes it can be quite distressing
when women come in and want to purchase
HRT but it's simply so expensive and
this is just one way that the government
wants to make it more accessible for
lots of women across England okay thanks
a lot
in other news SMP leadership candidate
Kate Forbes has said that she would have
voted against same-sex marriage as a
matter of conscience had she been an MSP
at the time she told the Scotsman she
would not have backed the legislation
but respected and defended the choice
that was made her comments have been
sharply criticized by some in the SNP
and former Scottish conservative leader
Ruth Davidson who is in a same-sex
relationship tweeted that Forbes has
just set fire to her leadership campaign
on the very same day she launched it
Supermarket Shoppers have been seeing
empty produce shells particularly
shortages of tomatoes and peppers it's
mainly due to disrupted harvests in
southern Europe and North Africa from
difficult weather Britain is
particularly reliant on Spain and
Morocco for bridge for produce in winter
energy bills are expected to rise by an
estimated 500 pounds a year despite an
expected reduction in off gems household
price cap analysts forecast the energy
regulator will cap household energy
bills each year at
3294 pounds from the 1st of April down
from the previous cap of
4279 but despite its customers we'll be
paying around 20 more on their bills
a man in Germany has become the third
known person to have been successfully
cured of HIV using a stem cell
transplant the 53 year old who's only
known as the Dusseldorf patient was
diagnosed in 2008.
he's been off his anti-retrovirus
medication for four years without
relapse
Japan is planning to raise the age of
consent from 13 to 16 a Justice Ministry
panel has proposed the change as part of
a series of reforms after rape
acquittals in recent years Drew protests
and public outcry
still to come on the program for you
this morning
Yuri sack advisor to the Ukrainian
defense minister will be joining us at 7
30 to discuss Biden's surprise visit to
Ukraine
um in addition to that the former
Northern Ireland secretary Lord Peter
Hayne will be joining us later on to
discuss the Northern Ireland protocol
[Music]
and at five past eight speaking to Jim
McMahon Shadow environment secretary
[Music]
Junior doctors will follow other health
workers and strike for 72 hours next
month in a dispute overpaid 98 of those
who voted back to the move the British
Medical Association said doctors were
frustrated and angry joined by the
minister for both mental health and
Women's Health Miracle field hi good
morning thanks for joining us why are 98
of doctors who voted wrong well I'm not
saying they're wrong it's disappointing
absolutely that they voted for strike
action but the BMA specifically on
Junior's doctor pay are asking for
around 26 which is just not affordable
and Junior doctors are in a different
position to other healthcare workers in
that they're not part of the independent
pay review body process they have a
multi-year settlement which was at 8.4
percent when it was last agreed and what
we would what I would say to them is
that we need to get back around the
table in terms of negotiating their next
uh pay settlement because obviously pay
is an issue and Junior doctors cover a
range of doctors from newly qualified
doctors right through to those who are
just about to to become consultants and
so we do need to obviously want to talk
to them about pay but 26 is not
something that realistically is
achievable what is so that's why we want
them to to get around the table when we
did the last multi-year pay settlement
and we settled at 8.4 percent you
absolutely took on point that on board
their points around pay and working
conditions but strike action is not
going to to resolve this and
particularly concerning is the issue
around them not wanting to cover a e and
things like itu that will have an impact
a serious impact on patients and so I
would say to the BMA come and talk to
the government look at the type of
strike action that they're taking and
you know a multi-year settlement means
that when they agree it when it's first
delivered that's something that we can't
undo right now the first notice is that
ambulance workers then call workers now
doctors there's a common theme there and
the government's on the wrong side of
this argument well this is impacting on
all four nations where health is
devolved it's you know an issue in Wales
it's an issue in Scotland Northern
Ireland and England so you know we're
not seeing something in England which is
the area I'm responsible for
um that that isn't happening in other
parts of the country so pay is an issue
but you know we have a responsibility to
the taxpayer as well for every one
percent of the pay rise we give that's
700 million pounds we have to find and
we can only find that in one of three
ways we rather have to tax people more
which is something we absolutely do not
want to do rather have to borrow the
money which we saw the impact of doing
that a few months ago when we borrow
more than we can afford all we have to
take out of existing budget and that
means as well you've got um an option as
far as windfall taxes are concerned we
have brought in room for taxes and
they're paying for People's Energy
support right now so people who are
getting uh who have the energy price
guarantee the 400 pounds people are
getting off their energy bills 150
pounds of cancer tax the windfall tax is
being used to pay for that but let's be
clear a windfall tax is not going to pay
for 26 uh increase in pay for junior
doctors
um and I asked you how much you wanted
to offer them and you can't say on live
television I get that um you were a
nurse previously absolutely yeah
how does this sit with you when your
colleagues go on strike for the first
time ever yeah well absolutely I was a
nurse during the pay freeze and the pay
cap which you previously
um had to experience and it is really
difficult
um particularly uh when you the cost of
living is is high at the moment
um so absolutely and I don't think any
nurse uh takes the decision to go on
strike and many nurses in England
haven't taken that decision let's be
clear uh you know less than half of
trust in this country have got nurses on
strike but any nurse who goes on strike
it's a very very difficult decision and
they will be torn by doing that but what
and I know Pat um well I have a lot of
respect for Pat Cullen and I would say
to him
absolutely and I would say to her to
give England the same deal as she's
giving Scotland they've called off
strikes in Scotland on based on talks on
pay for this forthcoming Year from April
that's exactly the space that we're in
and I would say to Pat to do the same in
England as she's done in Scotland call
off those strikes and let's see if we
can get a settlement for the forthcoming
years pay award so having previously
been a nurse you know how much they
struggle they don't earn enough money no
absolutely absolutely it is a struggle
and you know no one goes into nursing
not knowing that it's you know the wages
aren't fantastic and people do it
because they love the job and they want
to look after their patients and if I'm
not an MP I'll be go back to to being a
nurse so absolutely I understand uh the
pressures that's being faced but as a
minister I've also got responsible to
the ordinary working people across the
country that have to pay use their taxes
to pay those wages and you know 700
million pounds for every one percent
increase is something I have to justify
in terms of which services that money is
taken from talk to me about HRT and the
fact that it's going to be cheaper for
women to buy and also what about those
women who can't take it what are you
going to do for them yeah no absolutely
and I think for too long the menopause
the impact on women of the menopause has
been underestimated that people think
it's just simply your period stopping
and a few hot flashes and for many many
women it's a lot more than that it's
debilitating and many women don't
actually really realize they're going
through the menopause whether it's mood
swings whether it's brain fog whether
it's not sleeping palpitations and we're
not talking about for a few days weeks
or months years that women have to go
through this HRT is one way to acquire
here
absolutely and you know HRT Works
significantly well in a huge number of
women and we're almost victims of our
own success that we've seen a 50
increase in the number of women taking
HRT and sometimes that does put pressure
on supplies but reducing the cost we do
not want as a government costs to be a
barrier to women starting HRT knowing
the difference that it can make but HRT
isn't for everyone some women don't want
to take it for a variety of reasons they
may be on other health conditions or
medication for some women it doesn't
work despite trying numerous types of
HRT that's some of the concern yeah and
for some women they get side effects as
well so there are other um kind of
treatments options for HRT as well and
that's why we're setting up what
One-Stop well women clinics across the
country so that women can get expert
advisors Dr as nurses there's
practitioners who are experts in the
menopause and we want women to be able
to access those services so that if HRT
isn't working for them that they have
other options and they can get the help
and advice that they need how helpful is
it that people like Boris Johnson and um
Liz trust almost forgot her name
um
talking about jets for Ukraine from the
sidelines I mean that's not helpful is
it well I think you know obviously Boris
did a lot for Ukraine in terms of
generating the initial support when the
conflict started but you know Rishi has
been very clear he wants to support
Ukraine further and in fact he's getting
allies from around the world to try and
uh increase the support that's for you
Craig and he is talking to the defense
secretary Ben Wallace about what planes
could be available but we have to make
sure that these are planes that can be
used relatively quickly what we don't
want is to give them planes that take
months of training for their pilots to
use so those discussions are happening
behind the scenes but absolutely our
full support is behind Ukraine we're
coming up to the year's anniversary on
Friday and there'll be a minute silence
at 11 o'clock to commemorate that around
the country and people can and take some
time out to remember that and the impact
it's having on all our lives and not
just the people of Ukraine
um but absolutely those discussions are
going on behind the scenes about how we
can support them further um other
discussions going on kind of scenes
Northern Ireland protocol we're going to
get a deal this week I don't know about
this week I know that the prime minister
is working really hard on working with a
number of politicians from across
Northern Ireland politicians within the
EU to try and resolve this the Northern
Ireland protocol isn't working for
Northern Ireland right now and it does
need to be resolved it's a key reason
why there's no functioning assembly in
government in Northern Ireland that's
not great for the people of Northern
Ireland's Health who just talked about
the menopause health is a devolve matter
in Northern Ireland what we're
introducing here to reduce costs of
hormone replacement therapy here can't
be done in Northern Ireland at the
moment because there's no function in
government so it's having a day-to-day
impact on people's lives and it's a key
priority for the Prime Minister let me
squeeze one in very quickly you're a
woman of the world Kate Forbes who wants
to be the next first minister in
Scotland saying that she would not have
backed same-sex marriage 1970s on the
phone well you know that's a matter for
the s p to decide who they want to be
there the next leader look I'm
personally uh supportive of equal
marriage I voted for it actually for
Northern Ireland the last time their
assembly was out
um and Westminster had to take that
decision but it is a matter for the s p
and then it'll be a matter for the
people of Scotland where they decide
that the leader that they then have is
someone they want to continue with great
to see you thanks very much for joining
us thank you
uh some breaking news for speaking us
here at Sky Center public borrowing in
the financial year to date is 30.6
billion less than predicted by the
office for Budget responsibility
according to the last set of official
figures before next month's budget the
office for National statistics reported
a 5.4 billion Surplus for the chancellor
in January 80 by the highest January
figure for self-assessment income tax
receipts since monthly records began in
April of
1999. let's get more
um excuse me let's speak to tomorrow now
tomorrow are your thoughts on what we
heard from the minister there well no
compromise it sounds like with the with
the junior doctors who as Maria
Caulfield pointed out are not in the pay
review body as some other public sector
workers are they were given eight
percent pay rise over four years
beginning in 2019 so two percent a year
and they now say that compared to 2008
their pay has gone down in real terms by
26 percent and you can't argue within 98
vote for or a strike among those who
turned out obviously enormous strength
of feeling there but the government's
stance is that that is an unaffordable
pay rise and they hope that they can get
the doctors around the table to talk
about something Maria Caulfield
described as more reasonable but we're
looking at a 72-hour walkout by Junior
doctors next month and had a pretty
bleak assessment of the impact that
would have on patients from the NHS
providers from saffron caudry who said
that we've already seen a hundred and
forty thousand appointments canceled
since this wave of industrial action
began at the start of this year and when
you start looking at withdrawing
emergency cover things are going to get
very difficult yeah but we can quote all
of this to the government they're not
budging they're not budging the
Chancellor's view is that
inflation controlling inflation is key
and there's a situation now with the pay
of nurses and ambulance workers that the
government seems to be content to let
these strikes go ahead and say we're
looking at next year's pay which is the
pay that begins from April and steeming
to hope that those strikes might Peter
out once they start negotiating next
year's pay they won't look at the kind
of one-off payment that I know the
health secretary Steve Barkley had at
one stage been pushing for interesting
that Maria Caulfield said that the
nurses in England she hoped would be
offered by their Union the sort of deal
that they've got in Scotland where
nurses strikes have just been called off
after they accepted 6.5 rise for next
year she's saying that she hopes the
nurses in England start talking about
next year's pay but for the public
sector workers they're saying we want to
see a pay rise immediately and there's
going to be a lot of disruption before
the beginning of the next financial year
okay for now tomorrow thanks very much
indeed quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this will be the last day of the current
mile spell which has seen temperatures
in double figures for most the weather
will turn colder for the rest of the
week with the risk of overnight Frost
and wintry showers
just want to update you on the most
remarkable earthquake survival stories
to emerge from Syria here we go this
baby girl who was born beneath the
rubble of her family's shattered home
she survived still connected you
remember via the umbilical cord to her
mum who was killed along with her father
and four siblings her aunt and uncle
have adopted her and named her Afra
which was her mom's name
oh poor little thing
she's got a challenge ahead of her
hasn't she um right let's um update you
on other stories this morning stung by
Battlefield losses but with his forces
still in control about a fifth of
Ukraine
um Vladimir Putin will this morning lay
out his plans for the war as it enters
its second year the US President Joe
Biden unveiled huge new support for
Ukraine during an unannounced visit
yesterday and today he's in Poland with
me he's your second advisor to Ukraine's
defense minister Heights good to see you
thank you very much for joining us
how much did it help having President
Biden in time
it was a surprise visit that of course
gave a huge morale boost it's a very
powerful motivating factor for
ukrainians if you just look at how you
know the majority of Ukrainian people
what they were writing yesterday on
social media how people were responding
to this visit of course it's uh
everybody was jubilant and the reason
why the reaction is such is because
this visit of course sends a very
powerful message not just to ukrainians
it sends a powerful message to the
Kremlin as well and this message goes
that Ukraine will definitely win this
war
Russia will never win this war because
for Russia this is an unwinnable and
unsustainable war and it also sends a
message to A Wider International
audience that
um the Western allies will continue to
stand with Ukraine until Victory and of
course we hope that
as our president said yesterday that
this year will be the year of victory
what does it say to countries like Iran
who we know are supplying drones and the
like
um to Russia and also to China who are
reportedly considering offering lethal
weapons to Russia
with regards to Iran of course there are
a lot of diplomatic efforts in the
National Arena and not just by Ukraine
but by our allies as well to try to stop
the delivery of these drones and you
know there were there was information
that Russia was trying to even negotiate
the purchase of cruise missiles from
Iran so of course that's work in
progress and unfortunately for now
Russia still has some quantity of
Iranian drones which are hitting Ukraine
Ukrainian energy infrastructure our
peaceful cities but we're getting good
at shooting them down because our air
defense capabilities improve as well
thanks for that firsthand yeah well when
I was in care yeah well so you are an
eyewitness of the improved capability of
Ukrainian Air Force and air defense
so um as for China of course uh China is
a you know major player on the
international Arena and
um it seems logical that China should be
interested as a major player in an
International
rule-based International order so
we on our side we hope that China will
continue to at least have a pragmatic
approach to you know Russia's aggression
against our country and we hope that
this information doesn't materialize
because uh you know of course for us it
is important to continue to isolate
Russia and
making sure that it is not able to shop
around for more weapons for more
ammunition in other countries is as well
an important factor so you'll want to
know more about this 500 million dollar
package 550 billion dollar package 500
500 million yeah 415 million pounds lots
of figures to look at
um what's how's it going to be used what
is it
well it's a lot of ammunition for the
heavy artillery it's ammunition for
Hymer systems
armored vehicles and of course the main
our main objective at this stage you
know we've been able to
stabilize the front line uh it's of
course Fierce and very intense in some
parts of the front line but right now we
are preparing for our counter offensive
because like I said before we hope that
this is a year of our Victory and for
this we need to deoccupy those
temporarily occupied territories and all
these weapons will be used efficiently
by the Ukrainian Army to achieve these
goals and of course we're still talking
to our partners on a daily basis about
you know the provision of long-range
missiles about the tanks which we hope
will come soon and about the fighter
jets because uh it's for us to improve
our capability and to basically to
achieve our goal which which is in the
interest of the whole of the European
country
uh to restore peace to restore in
territorial Integrity of Ukraine uh we
need those weapon systems that we are
requesting to be on the front line
sooner rather than later
Friday is the anniversary of the War uh
The Invasion
um what do you expect to happen
uh
for the last two weeks there was always
a risk of renewed uh more intensified
Russian offensive it has not happened
yet and partly because the last 12
months during the last 12 months
Ukrainian Army was able to significantly
degrade Russian military capability and
we have seen that in a simple fact that
during the last six months the only
thing that they were able to gain
control of are the ruins of the city of
Soledad so their capability to carry out
an offensive of that magnitude is
probably degraded but at the same time
the risk of missile strike for example
remains very high in our Air Force
command yesterday issued a warning
towards to all ukrainians that we have
to be vigilant and you know if air rate
Sirens ring out people who need to seek
shelter because indeed Russia does have
a liking for these symbolic dates and we
have to be and we are prepared for any
turn of events but this will be a year
of Ukraine's resilience and a year of
Russia's failures
um and just to go back to China some
suggestions that they could possibly be
the one to broker a peace deal between
you and Russia is that something that
might be on the cards
um well look as far as uh ending this
war now there's a very deep
understanding within our allies that it
will have to be ended on the battlefield
and um and Ukraine does have a 10-step
peace plan which has been announced by
our president which has been discussed
with our allies and there's a broad
agreement that you know this plan is
logical and should be implemented so at
the moment we welcome you know all
diplomatic efforts aimed towards helping
Ukraine win this war
and once we win this war hopefully soon
then we will talk about things like
reparations for the damages that
Russians have done to our country
International Tribunal for the war
crimes that they have committed and our
future steps okay um it's good to see
you and hopefully it's as peaceful as
possible on Friday thank you very much
absolutely thank you thank you a
reminder there's a special program
Russia at war at Putin's home front
that's tonight 8 30 here on Sky News
in other news more than 60 British
companies recently took part in the
world's biggest trial of a four-day
working week and almost all of them
found it so successful they've made the
change permanent or at least extended it
Alice has more on how employees found a
better work-life balance
could the five-day working week become a
thing of the past for those at the Royal
Society of biology it already has
they were one of 61 organizations taking
part in the pilot and they're keeping
the four-day week we see there's
actually been a decline in the amount of
sick days taken During the period of the
trial we were starting off sick leave at
around about the you know five four to
five days perhaps per person per year on
average it's down to less than two at
the moment so I think it's a really
substantial difference actually
employees now have a slightly longer
working day but they say it's worth it
weekends can be quite hectic the two-day
weekend so it's been quite nice to have
that extra day you see your friends and
family on the two days when they're also
free and then you get that extra day off
during the week just to do all your
chores or just to have that time to
yourself to relax so it's really made a
big difference to my mental health I
think of the 2 900 staff who took part
in the pilot 39 said they were less
stress compared with the start of the
trial the number of sick days dropped by
around two-thirds and there was also a
57 decrease in the number of people
leaving companies compared with the same
period the previous year
the pandemic was key in forcing
workplaces to become more flexible but
not everyone believes a shorter week is
the future
I think a four day week sounds good in
principle but in practice how many
companies are going to be able to
actually support employees well-being if
they're going from having a normal
five-day week and then cramming that
down into four days we do a five day
week but we work 10 till four so we
shorten the days and that means that the
employees get to have that work-life
Harmony but they're not actually
shortening their week with the findings
of the pilot being presented to the
House of Commons today your four day
week could be just around the corner
Alice Porter Sky News
so who's celebrating their birthday the
steamy also we were talking about before
the break is Jilly Cooper the queen of
the steamy romance novel who is 86 today
I wrote Riders of course and jump which
was a big clue if you knew before the
break um happy birthday to Julie Cooper
uh she started her career as a
journalist writing a column on a sex
class apparently and a marriage and the
like and there she is picking up her
award at the palace
uh now if she sunax cabinet meets this
morning behind the scenes negotiations
continuing as he inches closer to a new
post-brexit trade deal for Northern
Ireland it's reported that some
ministers could resign if the Prime
Minister dumps the Northern Ireland
protocol bill in any new deal joining us
now is the former Northern Ireland
secretary Lord Hayne hello to Lord hey
it's always good to see you thanks for
joining us what a mess all this is
yes it is it was created by Boris
Johnson who's now and since tried to
wriggle his way out of it but the reason
it's such a problem
and brexit was always going to be a
problem for Northern Ireland because the
Republic of Ireland and Great Britain
joined the European Union at exactly the
same time in
1972-73. so for Britain to leave it for
the UK to leave it means that they
either had to be a border across the
island of Ireland and we know what that
would mean all the toxicity of the past
with the Catholic population
wanting closer if not United links with
the Republic to the South and the
unionist population the Protestant
population wanting to retain the link
with the UK once
um the UK left the European Union there
had to be an external border of the EU
somewhere either it was across the
island of Ireland which I say would
inflame all the old problems or there
had to be checks across the Irish Sea
from England Scotland Wales into
Northern Ireland now Boris Johnson
agreed as part of a a a sort of a rapid
exit to get it done in his phrase he
agreed to put it down the Irish sea and
then denied it and has sought to undo it
breaking an international treaty ever
since so this is a Moment of Truth
really and and I applaud Richie sooner
for trying to break through the mess
that uh Boris Johnson created and to put
Northern Ireland's interests first
instead of the extreme
dogmatists on his own back benches
so what's the fix how are they going to
fix it
well first of all you need to get rid of
the all the sort of obstacles to Goods
coming into Northern Ireland the problem
has been
that uh those goods whether they are
Supermarket products or Veterinary
products or pharmaceutical products
whatever it might be coming from England
Scotland or Wales into the Northern
Ireland if they were going to remain in
Northern Ireland that's the same as
remaining in the UK
if they were then going to go across the
border into the Republic of Ireland
and therefore into the European Union
say those goods were coming from let's
say China
or another country where the same safety
standards say the same food standards
are not the same as they are in the EU
which are very high and therefore
Brussels would be worried about being
undercut
and standards falling and so they'd want
to know about any Goods coming over the
IRSC into Northern Ireland then across
into the European Union that's where the
problem has arisen there's now a
proposal which I think has been more or
less agreed for green and red lens but
checks are on Goods that might be going
across the Irish Border into the
European Union for other Goods just
going into Northern Ireland then they
would be as before in the Green Lane and
that should get rid of a lot of the
aggravation and and also the the sense
of
threat of unionists feel that the
Protestant population feels about its
future with the rest of the UK
but that's a border control isn't it
well it was always going to have to be
some sort of check there always has been
there always have been checks uh on the
export of livestock and plants from
England Scotland or Wales into Northern
Ireland because the island of Ireland is
a single ecosphere so now there will be
a few more checks but they can be
unobtrusive because at the last London
has agreed to share in real time data
with Brussels as to what is coming
across that border so that they can be
periodic checks it's all done
electronically and it can remove a lot
of the
really aggravating and costly to a lot
of businesses uh checks that they've
been as a result of Boris Johnson's deal
so I think that's the core of it they're
then a couple of sticky issues because
Union is quite understandably feel that
they don't have any say anymore on some
of the regulations covering trading
rules because Northern Ireland will
remain in the single Market in the
Customs Union of Europe whereas of
course brexit took England's Scotland
and Wales out of it there'll still be
some some couple of sticky issues one is
that Northern Ireland politicians feel
they should be consulted
over what is happening in in their part
of the world and that's quite legitimate
in my view there is a democratic deficit
Norway solves this problem noise in the
single market like Northern Ireland but
it's outside the European Union
so whenever the European Union wants to
propose a new regulation of let's say
different standards in cars to take an
example or food
and if that affects Norway they then
consult the Norwegian government even
though it doesn't have ministers like
Britain used to have and therefore
Northern Ireland used to have in the
European Union making those laws and
that seems to work quite well I hope
something like that is going to be
adopted as part of this deal that Rishi
sunak is discussing there's then a bit
of a theological argument that it
matters a lot to brexiteers but frankly
doesn't matter in ordinary life to
Northern Ireland citizens whatever their
politics whatever their religion and
that is that the European Court
ultimately has the final say if there's
a dispute between two companies uh one
thinking that its rival is undercutting
on standards and therefore they go to
the court that happens very rarely and
as it's been inflamed by um some
unionist politicians in some Tory
brexiteer hardliners say oh well we
can't have foreign courts uh making our
laws well it's not quite like that and I
think a proposal to put Northern
Ireland's Court first I could solve it
sorry if this is quite complicated okay
but I just wanted to pick you up on
Norway if I may am I not writing saying
that Norway has free movement of people
with the EU
it's part of the single market so in
that sense yes it does but it is my
point is that it's consulted on uh it's
and there will be free movement across
the border between Northern Ireland and
the Republic of Ireland
please understand I've got to get sorted
so it is complicated to sort but with
Goodwill and I think rishi's soon I've
shown that instead of dogmatism okay
because this whole debate has been
poisoned by dogmatism and lack of trust
why would Brussels trust London when
Boris Johnson's promising all along as
did Liz trust to tear up the the deal
that they'd agreed an international
treaty international law Britain's never
done anything like that before and
obviously the EU is saying well we can't
trust you guys anymore which is really
bad for Britain who's stopped was very
high in the International Community that
we don't stand by what we agree to so
the whole relationship's been poisoned
and I think to his credit rishis who
knows tried to unscramble that but it's
it's difficult yep
um interesting little thank you for
joining us as always thank you it's a
pleasure
I just want to show you this first
generation iPhone still in its box as
sold at auction four
more than 63
000 a hundred times its original price
there you go you remember it was
launched in 2000 and seven by late Apple
Chief Steve Jobs Karen green received
hers as a gift but never opened it as
she just bought one herself as well over
the years collectors have grown to
consider the first iPhone as a cultural
and technological artifact there you go
it doesn't actually change that much has
it there you go um all today's top
stories coming up in just a moment stay
tuned
[Music]